[Musica]
io sono imperfetto e ne sono felice
ma la bella notizia sapete qual è che
anche voi lo siete tutti siete
imperfetti tu tu tu tu tu
siamo tutti imperfetti il problema
sapete qual è e la società questa
società che ci impone di raggiungere
obiettivi altissimi se non era bella
macchina se non era bella casa se non
hai bel fisico se non ha il bel lavoro
non sei nessuno e alla fine siamo tutti
scoppiati ed infelici la vita è
imperfetta
noi siamo imperfetti perché siamo umani
e come umani siamo perfetti
così come siamo qualcuno dice che siamo
sua immagine e se siamo a sua immagine
siamo perfetti mi conoscerete forse
qualcuno mi conosce
forse qualcuno no io sono il papà di
alba alba e una bambina con la sindrome
di down la nostra storia ha fatto il
giro del mondo
e ancora mi domando il perché siamo
conosciuti ovunque
forse a volte mi sono detto perché i due
imperfetti si sono incontrati i due
handicappati della società hanno trovato
una loro strada
io uomo single gay con un forte
desiderio di paternità e lei bambina
neonata lasciata in ospedale dalla madre
rifiutata da tante coppie per la sua
sindrome di down per tanti
noi siamo un espressione di imperfezione
e invece per me alba e perfetta così
come
perché perché la disabilità di alba non
mi spaventa questo non vuol dire che io
non abbia considerazione del suo
problema
ma la questione è guardare la persona
c'è prima alba c'è prima la bambina e
poi c'è la disabilità qualcuno mi ha
chiesto ma se tu avessi una bacchetta
magica
la guarire sti alba non ci ho dormito
una notte
sapete poi quando diventi padre ti fanno
un interrogativo sul tuo figlio non ci
dorme la notte
alla fine mi sono detto no io albano la
guarin ray
innanzitutto alba non è malata alla
sindrome di down
la sindrome di down non è una malattia
ma poi perché abbiamo tutti questo vizio
di voler curare per forza tutto di voler
guarire e rendere perfetto chi si può
arrogare il diritto di stabilire chi o
cosa è normale chi si può arrogare il
diritto di stabilire che cos'è la
bellezza
che bello e chi non lo è per me alba e
bellissima ed è una bimba perfetta
nonostante la sua disabilità
vi voglio raccontare una storia una
storia che per me è stata molto
importante che mi ha reso più grande tra
le tante esperienze di volontariato e in
india in africa sono arrivato anche a
lourdes avevo 16 anni la prima volta nel
treno bianco
voi sapete il treno bianco a una serie
di vagoni e c'è il vagone del barellato
il barrel lato è quel vagone dove ci
sono tutti gli ammalati gravi che sono
in barella e fanno il viaggio distesi a
quell'epoca io conobbe luigi aveva
trent'anni altobruno un ex surfista un
fisico pazzesco è già era nel barellato
quando vide luigi era
steso e la madre gli manteneva le gambe
per cercare di non farlo andare di qua e
di là con il camminare del treno allora
gli proposi alla madre di sostituirla
pensando vabbè un'oretta lo conoscerò
parlammo tutta una notte
parlammo tutta una notte io seduto curvo
a mantenere le gambe di luigi parlammo
della nostra vita dei nostri desideri
delle nord dei nostri progetti delle
nostre aspirazioni parlammo della sua
malattia della sclerosi multipla
quando arrivammo a lourdes all'alba gli
chiese luigi che cos'è che ti fa più
paura lui lucidissimo mi disse
l'indifferenza e la gente che prova pena
per la mia condizione
io e luigi siamo rimasti amici per tutta
la vita per tutta la sua vita e lo siamo
ancora
e l'ho accompagnato nel viaggio è più
importante la sua vita
eppure io vi assicuro che nonostante la
sua cecità
nonostante la voce che non c'era più
nonostante il suo corpo completamente
paralizzato luigi era una presenza la
vita non è perfetta la vita imperfetta
noi non siamo perfetti c'è un problema
un problema serio che molti confondono
ci sono gli ammalati e ci sono i
disabili gli ammalati si trovano in una
condizione di passaggio o guariscono o
non ce la fanno
luigi non è guarito e poi ci sono i
disabili i disabili non sono ammalati si
trovano in una condizione di vita
stabile alba non è ammalata e una
disabile
una bambina diversa è questo il problema
il problema è capire che la gente non
riesce a vedere nelle persone disabili
la persona e poi la disabilità
la vita non è perfetta noi siamo
imperfetti
io ho scelto di portare i miei difetti
come esempio perché sono i difetti che
ci rendono unici e irripetibili sono i
difetti che ci rendono umani
la vita non è perfetta